[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
one
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
one
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
to
[Music]
hey we're back once again that's why i
was like where'd sophie go
because you're likely that
these girls are making fun of me because
of my [ __ ] facebook etiquette
i'll post some [ __ ] or say something and
then i'll like it yeah
i like what i said like i was like god
damn i'm funny
yeah yeah yeah i'm to the point where i
don't care anymore and they go well you
like a grandpa
i said i used to care i did i used to
care
but i think facebook's so [ __ ] played
out now that i don't care what happens
on facebook i only
i was telling them i'm only checking to
see if people are saying
something to me or mentioning or about
you or sharing something or saying
something but that's it if it's if it's
not directly to me
i hate when i click into that [ __ ] it
goes to the data stream to
to show me what all my friends are
saying i don't care that's social media
social yeah yeah it's played out it's
like why why bother having to play that
i actually like
i think i like um i like um
what's wrong with the [ __ ] what what's
up
i like the thing with the dick what's
that other thing
i like instagram that tic tacs what's
with the tic tacs
these kids nowadays get off my lawn
i i like instagram and and uh youtube
better
yeah than facebook know i'm sick of
facebook
i mean like i said i still post stuff
for the show on there but it's i post on
instagram and [ __ ] like that too
facebook's starting to remind
remind me of myspace remember when
myspace really started to get played out
too much graphics and too much music and
too much that's just that [ __ ] who
cares
it's kind of it's too much for my old
yeah i'm over stimulated
i tried to go back to [ __ ] facebook
just or excuse me
to see what it was like i didn't even
know i couldn't get in it supposedly for
a while it was it's still there
i don't even remember my passion i think
it's still there it's like a dead ball
like [ __ ]
15 years i don't think i think it's like
you need an app
yeah and i couldn't download the app on
my [ __ ] device
it was like too old yeah okay but i
think i think it's still there
it's like a damn dead ball it's just
suspended out there well
i heard that there were some people that
refused to leave it that they're this
like the
the last [ __ ] i guess aol is still
there too
aol remember that [ __ ] yeah damn
uh sandra was said a couple she said a
good book review today thank you very
much i really did like that book and i
recommend it
uh horror story by grady hendricks was
the one that i reviewed
um and she said that i have different
bangs they're the same bangs i just i
usually sweep them off to the side
but today i just like did them straight
down just for whatever reason because
they were sticking up funny and they
were giving me a
pain all right so uh we actually ended
up
even though i said yesterday that we
were going to expand out the matinee
pool to movies that came out in the last
10 years because i was like sick of
always looking for brand new ones we
actually did end up watching a brand new
one last night just came out
in early september of 2020 this is a
british film called the owners now you
picked this one we rented this on vod i
think it was 6.99
yeah um this is basically like
a reverse revenge flick where you have
like
a bunch of british thugs
who what now you're giving the movie
away i'm not no no no that's
it yeah that's the promise oh yeah
that's the premise let's say that yeah
i'm not i'm not giving anything it says
like right on the [ __ ] description of
it it's just a good old british movie
it's like a bunch of british thugs like
one of whose moms
like works for this old couple that
lives in this big fancy
manor house and they decide that they're
gonna break into this house while the
old people are out and like steal other
money
and uh from there like things
don't go the way that they planned and
also one of them's
girlfriends gets roped into it too the
girlfriend being played
by maisie williams i think her name is
from game of thrones so she is like the
biggest
uh star in this one and i guess this was
like a big vehicle for her
now the this movie was directed by
julius berg i think this is his first
movie and something that i didn't know
when we watched it because we just kind
of watched it randomly because the
trailer looked good was that this is
actually based on a french graphic novel
called uh i'm not gonna attempt to
pronounce the french even though i took
four years of it
but um it basically means a full moon
night or night of the full moon
is like the name of the french graphic
novel this movie
reminded me a lot of if you saw
don't breathe the one about the
criminals that broke into the
like the blind old guy's house and then
uh you know he ended up being like more
than they could handle
um this also really really strongly
reminded me of lucio fulchi's
house of clocks which is kind of one of
his lesser-known ones because i think it
was made for italian tv
now that one had some supernatural [ __ ]
going on
like the people broke into the into this
creepy old people's house like castle
and they then like often times started
running in reverse you know what i mean
so there was like a supernatural element
to that but this
tonally it reminded me of this even
though this is more like
like this is more like don't breathe or
maybe hush or something like that where
you know you think that it's gonna go
one way because you're like oh these
people it's like a home invasion
and you know they're breaking into
something like a vulnerable person's
house i can hush like the woman was
deaf or whatever um but then it turns
out that the person is
like not the victim that you think they
are um
i actually it seems like because you
were saying that you were looking at
reviews of this
review is it's got like four stars i
think on imdb
out of 10 and like i was reading some of
the critical reviews and some people
were just ripping it apart and i was
like oh
that's so sad because it was it was a
fun little ride it's not the most
like i don't know it's not the most
unique thing i've ever seen but
yeah you know there's nothing wrong with
this one it's kind of predictable you
know a little bit because we were kind
of calling some of that in the beginning
but you know i mean i thought it was fun
like i don't like slow movies usually
and this wasn't slow
so yeah it basically moved along at a
good clip and i thought
what was good about it was that you knew
that
[ __ ] wasn't gonna go the way that the
thugs thought it was gonna go like you
knew some [ __ ] was gonna go awry
but you didn't know quite what was gonna
happen and like a few times they kind of
strung you along
and then they kind of like went in this
slightly different direction the way you
thought it was going to go so i thought
that was kind of cool so i was like the
whole time i'm sitting there going
what you know what is the [ __ ] end
game going to be like what are these
people gonna
gonna do you know what i mean because
they never really
you know you never really know what they
were gonna do or how like [ __ ] was going
to end up happening
i was catching kind of a clockwork
orange vibe from it it had a little bit
of that too yeah
but really you know if they were if they
were tearing this movie up i think it's
kind of unjustified there's nothing
wrong with this movie
yeah it's a movie yeah it's not like i
said it's not fantastic
it's not super original it's just a
british fun
horror kind of movie revenge kind of
move
it's not really a revenge movie it's
just a [ __ ] weird horror movie
yeah it was kind of like or it kind of
gave me like a little bit of the
uh the strangers kind of vibe except
like opposite
you know read into [ __ ] too much well i
think people are too picky
everyone's expecting like a masterpiece
like a every single time
like an award-winning film it's not an
award-winning film
no it's just a fun little like you said
you throw it on at night and you won't
be bored for
an hour and a half or however long yeah
you're drinking and you're [ __ ]
watching these [ __ ] bridges which is
what
watch this damn british movie
we see here's the deal you know what i
mean look in the british i'm gonna
i'm not gonna sit here and just you know
start stroking [ __ ] on the british or
anything no
it's not really my deal oh my goodness
yeah
but it's like the british are really
good about
writing a [ __ ] script and putting it
in a bright setting to where they'll
tell you a good story and it didn't
really cost a lot of money to make it
they were real [ __ ] good at low
budget movies
they could take something that's got a
small budget
and pull it off and it wouldn't look low
budget yeah i mean this all
one it was in one house just in one
house yeah it takes place i think it was
in kent it's on wikipedia
just do it on the back of you know of
decent writing and [ __ ] good
filmography and [ __ ] just tell the
story you know
and i really i liked all the characters
like you even kind of like the thug
characters except for gaz he's an
[ __ ] but like
the other ones are kind of sympathetic
because you have the feeling that they
just kind of got roped into it and
they're like
you know they're broke and it's like
this is gonna like change their whole
life like stealing the money from these
old people
like because you know they're rich and
they can spare it
but it's what i like that they made like
the three characters like really really
distinct
you know what i mean like gaz is like
the the psychopath who just like tears
[ __ ] up for no reason
then you have terry who was kind of like
the chubby guy and his mom like works at
the place
and he's kind of like it i don't know if
it was so much his idea but he was kind
of the one that put the idea in the
other one's head i think he thought he
was gonna win like points with his
friends like
yeah points like look how cool i am i
got you i got you yeah
yeah that's definitely so he was like
kind of insecure but you know kind of
like a nice dude you know
at heart sort of um and then the other
guy is just kind of like this regular
guy that's kind of reluctant to do it he
doesn't really want to do
any kind of violent [ __ ] but he wants
the money
so but they did a good job of that and i
really liked um
maisie williams's character the
girlfriend because it's believable
yeah i just you know what i mean it's
just like and i
i have to say too like the old people
that ran i think rita tushingham played
the
wife and she was great she was like
super creepy in this
but like because she was i don't even
did they even like tell what was
she seemed like she was mentally ill
yeah i think she did i think she was all
the slimers or
something where her mind was going
because the husband was like trying to
keep her mentally fresh she needed to
look out for her and stuff
she was alzheimer's yeah it was
something like that but she was [ __ ]
great at it i'm not sure if
she really had alzheimer's or she was
pretending that's what i mean it's like
they didn't have it they left it sort of
ambiguous
but like i said this reminded me a lot
of house of clocks if you haven't seen
that like it's almost exactly the same
except for that being like supernatural
yeah
sandra says oh baby yoda in the back
yeah we put we put a little baby
back there this shoulder is going on
about [ __ ] hellraiser being british
and that really good
i just said that they made good good low
budget movies british again but
the the um hell raiser was a low budget
movie
and it wasn't that it came out it looked
good man you know
and uh you know stands it stands the
test of time even today you know
and i think it's just it's just kind of
the craftsmanship you know
the british made good [ __ ] they knew how
to work with those tight budget
i just were american it would be [ __ ]
up
i liked that other british movie that we
saw the other day too the one about like
the old guy that was up in the attic and
yeah [ __ ] that was like pretty good i
like yeah they were probably savaging
that online too
well that's the thing it's i kind of
like that [ __ ] i don't know it's
they're savaging the [ __ ] out of
bavarium that's what i mean so it's like
you can't really i didn't understand
that that was a good movie
yeah and vivarium was one of my favorite
movies from last year
good irish flick and like so it just
seems like
to an extent you can believe like if
everybody is coming out and saying like
this is the worst [ __ ] ever like don't
watch it
then okay but if something's getting to
a point where 50
of the people really like it and the 50
of people really hate it it's probably
still worth watching
yeah and like i said you can't have a
masterpiece every [ __ ] time like you
can't every movie can't just be like
yeah [ __ ] orgasmic it's like some of
them are just fine
and it's fine although bavarium was i
think it was a masterpiece of what it
was yeah i think it was too
i think it was too i've never seen a
horror sci-fi movie like
that it was totally new approach i
thought the acting was like incredible
yeah i never all the way around so i
don't know what people just want
and and you know the whole concept of
this [ __ ]
extra dimensional parasite that [ __ ]
with you
and they played on your fears like
really well you said it was a lot it was
like sort of like a nightmare you know
yeah yeah that's exactly and you know
it's
that's the thing so it's like this movie
if you really if you like those kind of
movies like if you like don't breathe or
something like that then
this would probably be right up your
alley like i said it's not the best
thing you've ever seen it's not the most
original thing you've ever seen but what
the [ __ ] is like hardly anything is
it's like if you're just gonna have like
a few drinks and like got an hour and a
half and want to watch kind of a cool
movie about some old people
[ __ ] up some young people yeah
[Laughter]
yeah it's worth it it's worth it you
know yeah and no
hold on one second that guy what's his
name jesse eisenberg's is that him
the guy from vivarium yeah and he was
also from uh
something's up with that guy he was also
in the social network i don't think i
don't think he saw that
he's lex luthor in the new supervisor
okay well i'll tell you what i
on the back of those two movies that i
saw i got i got confidence in in that
guy's projects
seems like he wants to get involved with
really high quality projects that are
well written
and they're not like huge budget movies
you know what i mean they're just a
[ __ ] good movie so i'd like to see
social network
i liked it i saw in the theater it's
about he he plays
um zuckerberg yeah zuckerberg now did he
did he like co-produce that or something
i don't know that was fairly early in
his career so i think that was the first
movie that i saw him and that was
years ago because bavaria and art of
self-defense he was involved in the
production too
yeah that was [ __ ] he wanted to but like
i said i always like when that happens
when you get these
um dudes that want to make cool [ __ ]
yeah that is like and even if they came
out and they were in one movie and they
made like all the money and then they're
like okay well [ __ ] it now i'm just
gonna
go do indie movies that i want to do now
that i have enough money to like not
worry about
keep an eye on that eisenberg guy well
like i said he's been around for a long
time
you should you would probably like the
social network it's like about the
founding of facebook
yeah you know what i mean like how it
started and it's kind of like about he's
the one in zombieland too
am i thinking yes yeah that's him right
here right
he's the kid yeah wait that's him right
i'm pretty sure i'm pretty sure it is
everything that's what i remember like
first seeing yeah
zombieland every time i re-watched
vivarium or art of self-defense i saw
more [ __ ] in it
yeah and you see that's like a yeah
that's like a sign of some [ __ ]
that that's the kind of movie i love i
totally forgot that he was indomitable
you remember zombieland right and we
just
and we just saw the [ __ ] we just saw
the sequel not too long ago eisenberg
was in that one
yeah woody harrelson is the baddest oh
yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah i remember that yeah i
remember that yeah yeah that was a good
movie too
yeah so he's in there that was a good
movie yeah i like that movie i like the
first one better than the second one but
the second one was fine i didn't see the
second one but
we saw the second one i loved the first
one i saw it a few times yeah it's funny
as [ __ ] yeah
i didn't see the first one yeah you did
because we rented it like the night
before we went to see the
sequel okay i remember we went to see
the sequel at the theater and i said oh
you should probably see the first one
so yeah that's right that's right that's
right the night before we went to see
the second one
i for some reason the the second one
stuck with me the first one didn't
didn't as much
see i like the second one with albus
right where they go to where elvis lives
yeah yeah
yeah they go to graceland graceland yeah
um i like the first one better but the
second one was
the first one just had so many like gray
lines and stuff it did
and like and bill murray i mean yeah
that's like yeah
all right so uh you ready to wrap it up
i'm ready to read it he's ready to wrap
it up he's i had to wake him up to like
get him in
unintentional old man
i'm fighting to stay awake watching a
movie and he's like yeah
i was showing her pale ryder yeah and
he's what
because before that she i showed her
that um
high plains i played which is a [ __ ]
great it's like that's like the crow
set in the old west yeah excuse me and
she liked that one so
pale ryder is kind of like an unofficial
follow-up to that
um but i started i like the movie but i
started to [ __ ] tripped off to sleep
i'd seen it a lot of times i've seen it
many times though you know i grew up
with
yeah so he's just like yeah you were
getting ready to fall asleep too
a little earlier but i woke myself up
but i got some water and got adjusted i
was like
i don't know i'm here for this all right
i can't stay awake in your
well the thing is is that high planes
drifter like you said they're
there was like gun fights and [ __ ] right
away like right away the whole thing
yeah
looking um no not not uh not pillows
sounds good though the characters are
really
developed yeah pale writer is more about
characters at the end [ __ ] goes down
yeah yeah all right so uh tom's got to
go back to sleep
and i got some more work to do actually
i might go in a minute and get some
coffee and
get get a piece of my leftover piece of
my birthday cake i think we got a little
bit left
yeah i got to make some good [ __ ] and
he's making meatloaf
yeah we're so domestic yeah
all right so uh we'll probably be on
again tomorrow
talking about oh oracle said ah poo i
missed the whole thing we'll be back
tomorrow though and you can watch it
after the
you can watch it'll post right up soon
we stream every single
well five days a week we stream all
right so we'll be back tomorrow talking
about another movie look he couldn't
even bother yeah i can't wait
to go all right
see you guys tomorrow bye